oh my God I'll see you in the finale
Monday marked the first live show of The
Voice
our first live show we got to do a big
one but Blake he's
sure he's got another championship in
the bag did you feel more competitive or
less competitive more competitive I
don't know where these people come from
or why I just don't know where they come
from we have so many great singers in
this country it's unbelievable Bodhi a
29 year old California Native and member
of Team Blake closed out the night with
a performance of joji's glimpse of us
close
my looking
hell I find
yeah safe to say all that left the
country singer and his wife fellow coach
Gwen Stefani borderline speechless I
wasn't expecting that kind of a song out
of you because your voice is so
unbelievably good that you could do
literally anything thank you it's like
mind-blowing the effect that you have on
people and man I'll tell you you know if
if the idea was for you to honor your
family for that performance I think you
did it and
and you blew us all away in the process
dude you oh my God I'll see you in the
finale
and while Blake is confident he's going
to win this season Gwen told E.T she's
working hard to make sure he doesn't add
another trophy to his mantle honestly
everybody's got really good uh team
members and it's going to be tough
Blake's losing this season
the singer is back on the show for the
first time since she and the country
singer tied the knot I can't believe I'm
back what is your favorite thing about
being back being on set with Blake is
just pretty fun like happy anywhere you
know what I'm saying oh we know what
you're saying Gwen
[Music]
last month Blake announced that season
23 will be his last on the hit singing
competition and when ET chatted with the
coaches on Monday night they weighed in
on what they should get Blake for his
retirement
some kind of amazing alcohol
because he loves alcohol he has a new
show called barmageddon
and I feel like that's his happy place
that's a good Parting Gift he has
everything he has everything but I think
his favorite thing would be a bag of
corn like that would be honestly like he
would be so thrilled
um or fertilizer or something like that
if somebody gives me corn as a present
I'll just assume they hate me but it
makes sense I do love corn
maybe he just loves corn
[Music]